CHRIS YERGA: Thank
you so much, Bill.
And thank you all for coming
here to Playtime in Shanghai.
For those of you who have
some difficulty understanding
my funny accent,
this is probably
a good time to put your
translation earphones in.
My name is Chris Yerga.
I'm the Vice President
of Engineering at Google,
responsible for
Google Play in Asia.
I've been working in
the software industry
for about 25 years now.
But I can't imagine
any time that
was more exciting than
the one right now.
And the fact that we come
out here and see so many
of you, with all of your energy,
and passion, and enthusiasm
for apps and games, I
think that shows why.
So we've got a lot of great
content for you today.
I'm going to kick things off,
catching you up a little bit
on the latest
developments in Android.
And then we'll talk a
little bit about how
you can build a global
business on Google Play.
So Android, as you know, is
Google's open source operating
system.
It was released
several years ago
and has had incredible success.
This chart here shows the growth
in active Android devices.
And we're just so pleased
that we've gotten to a point
where we have far more than a
billion active Android devices.
But the other staggering
thing that sometimes I
have difficulty understanding
is that 1.5 million new devices
are running Android
and are being activated
each and every day.
So 1.5 million is a lot.
It's hard to get
your head around.
And so we did a thought
experiment, where we said,
what if we stacked all of those
1.5 million devices on top
of each other?
Would it go to the
roof of this building?
Would it go beyond the
roof of the building?
It turns out that when
you stack 1.5 million
of these Android devices
on top of each other,
it extends beyond the
peak of Mount Everest,
indeed even above the
cruising altitude of a jet
that many of us
took to come here.
So that's an Everest
worth of new devices
being activated every day.
And all of those devices
represent an opportunity
for all of you, as a
way to get your apps
and games into the hands
of many, many customers.
Now, success like that doesn't
happen just because of the work
that we at Google are doing.
Android is the result of
a global ecosystem that
includes 60 OEMs
building Android devices,
329 mobile carriers that
are selling these devices
and service in
over 190 countries.
And of course, the other
really important part
of that ecosystem
are the people that
are building great
apps and games
for Google Play and Android,
which is all of you.
The results of that
are impressive as well.
So globally, 78% of
the world's smartphones
run Android today and 62%
of the world's tablets.
So that's an incredible number.
And all of these people are
potential customers for you.
So that's why,
today, you're going
to hear us talk about
going global quite a bit.
That's because these
numbers represent
the global opportunity for
Android and Google Play.
86% of those devices run
Android 4.0 and above,
giving you the chance to use
the newest APIs to really
wow people with your content.
But as big as those
numbers are, there
are still 5 billion
people on this planet who
don't have a smartphone yet.
And so we're focused
on getting Android
into the hands of as many
of those people as possible.
And so we recently
announced Android One,
which is our
initiative to deliver
a powerful and beautiful Android
experience at a very low price
point that's appropriate
for many of the emerging
markets in Asia and
around the world.
We're also focused on not
just getting smartphones
into everybody's
hands, but also having
Android run on as many different
device types as is possible.
We recently this year announced
our Android TV initiative,
which is about running
Android on what is normally
the biggest and best display
screen in your house, which
is your TV.
And particularly
for those of you
who are building
Android games, the TV
represents a really great
opportunity for users
to enjoy those games, not
just when they're on the go
but when they're in their
living rooms as well.
And because it runs
Android, it means
that you can adapt your game
to run on the TV with very
minimal effort and investment.
And then from things very big to
things very small-- of course,
Android Wear is another
recently announced initiative
to get Android running on
wearable devices and devices
like wrist watches
that can not only
augment the experience
on a smartphone
with real-time notifications
and interaction,
but also integrate a variety
of health-related sensors,
pedometer, all
that sort of stuff.
And then finally, there's the
Android Automotive product,
which is about getting Android
directly into the entertainment
system of automobiles.
So across all of these
different types of devices,
we're really focused
on bringing Android
to people, wherever they are,
and whatever they're doing.
Now, when you talk about having
Android running on everything
from a television, to a tablet,
to a smartphone, to a wearable,
it's really important also
to have a user interface
that scales between
those screens
efficiently and gives some
consistency of experience.
This effort started
5,000 years ago,
with the invention of paper.
That actually happened
here in China.
And material design
is our contribution
to thinking about
what smart paper might
look like, here in the
present, in the 21st century.
We'll have some more details
about material design coming up
in the next talk.
Obviously, on top of all
that rides Google Play.
Google Play is installed on this
Everest worth of devices that
are being activated every day.
And the result of that
is we have Google Play.
That is your one-stop shop
for not only apps and games,
but also movies, books,
whatever entertainment content
our customers want.
And the results of that
have been just as impressive
as Android's own
success, with 50 billion
plus applications downloaded
in total from the Google Play
Store and an
additional 2 billion
of those being downloaded
each and every month.
So now I just want to
talk a little bit about--
of those 50 billion
applications,
games is an important category.
Games are very popular
with our users.
And one interesting
thing to think about here
is that games are the sort
of things that everybody
can appreciate and enjoy.
And in fact, our
metrics show that three
out of every four Android users
plays games on their device.
Now, that means that
games are reaching
people who probably
never really thought
of themselves as a gamer.
It's very broad.
And so with so many different
people playing games
on Android, that represents
a huge opportunity
for all of you.
And we're assisting
in this with something
we call Google Play
Game Services, which
enables features like
achievements, high score
lists, multiplayer matchmaking,
quests, leaderboards, and more.
And this is our opportunity to
provide some common services
so that you don't need to
make that investment yourself.
And the benefits are such that
100 million new users have
adopted Google Play Game
Services in just six months,
making it the fastest
growing mobile game
service of all time.
And for you, the
developer, what that means
is when people are using Google
Play Games enabled games,
they're more engaged.
So we did a case study
with one of our partners.
And their own
internal data showed
that users who use
Google Play Game
Services to see what
their friends were doing
and compete on high
scores, et cetera,
were 300% more likely to
come back after three days
and 400% more likely to
come back after seven days.
So it's a way not just to
help get your app discovered
through the social connections
people have with their friends,
but also to deepen retention.
So we talked a lot about
the numbers and the fact
that there's a
global opportunity.
So one of the main reasons we're
here today is to talk to you
and find out what we could
do for you to help you take
advantage of this opportunity.
As we mentioned, you'll hear
us use the word "go global"
quite a bit today.
There's a global
opportunity here,
with the 2 billion apps that
are being downloaded every month
across 190 countries.
And that opportunity
has been utilized
by triple the number
of developers who've
registered with Google
Play, from the Asia Pacific
region in particular.
So it's not just about
distributing your app globally.
We at Google take
a holistic approach
through the entire life cycle.
So it starts with developing
your application, as well
as distribution, and
then monetization,
and closing the loop with
metrics, and analytics,
and statistics, so
that you can optimize
the performance of your
app and the performance
of your business.
So today, I'm just going
to spend some time talking
about three of these areas--
in particular, development,
international distribution,
and monetization.
So as we mentioned before, in
the development of your app
and game, we highly
encourage you
to integrate Google Play
Game Services to get
the benefits of
discoverability and engagement
that we talked about.
And there's also
additional Google services
that we encourage
you to look at.
So AdMob has an SDK to help
monetize your app or game
through in-app advertising.
And then, also,
Google's cloud platform
is an important
offering as well.
Google's cloud platform allows
you to build your game or app
backend, using the same cloud
infrastructure that Google uses
for our own services,
so that if you have
a very fast, successful app, and
your users grow and skyrocket,
that you can scale with
it by letting Google
use its expertise
to help you scale,
rather than having to
do all that on your own.
And another important thing
is to focus on app quality
so that you're giving your users
the best possible experience,
which will then increase
your app and game
rankings in the store, which
then helps you in terms
of getting future installs.
We have a lot of services to
help you get good feedback
from your customers.
We also offer alpha
and beta testing,
so that you can test new
changes or new versions
of your app with a select,
small group of people first,
so that you can be
sure that you've
addressed all the quality
issues before you release it
to the world.
Getting ready for global
reach-- obviously,
with 190 countries globally
served by Google Play,
there's a lot of
different users out there.
And many of them
are coming online
from emerging markets,
where Android One, we hope,
was going to assist.
But the other thing is that
when you're localizing your app,
Google Play also offers,
in our developer console,
the ability for you to
upload your application
and then work directly
with translation services
to get your strings
and application
localized for a variety
of different customers.
Now obviously, monetization
is a topic that's
top-of-mind for many of us.
And we've worked
tirelessly at Google Play
to increase the
amount of ways that we
offer for your customers to
pay for your apps and games.
We've launched Google Play gift
cards in a number of markets.
And that has been very
popular with customers.
In addition, we've been adding
new forms of payment, Paypal
being the most recent example.
But I think the area where
we've had some of the most
success with our customers is
through direct carrier billing,
where we work with
mobile phone carriers
to enable their customers
to charge their app and game
purchases directly
to their phone bill.
And we've been working
with literally dozens
of different mobile carriers
globally to enable this.
We also have-- you can
monetize, obviously,
through a paid app download,
in-app purchasing, which
is very popular.
Many of our top grossing apps
utilize in-app purchasing
as their monetization strategy.
We've also added the ability
for subscription billing,
so that you can get a
recurring source of revenue
from your customers.
The results of that
have been quite large.
We announced that in the
period from June 2013 to June
of this year, we
paid out $5 billion,
in US dollars equivalent,
to our developer partners.
And that's a large
amount of money.
But it's not just
the amount of money.
But the other impressive thing
about that is that the growth
rate represents 2.5x
year-over-year growth.
So it's a huge market.
But it's also rapidly expanding.
And we welcome
all of you to help
build apps and games to partake
in the success yourself.
The way we think
about this is you're
not just building an app,
you're building a business.
And Google Play is there
to partner with you
in all the ways that
we'll be talking
about today, to help you
take your app to a business.
As I mentioned,
in conclusion, we
help you throughout
the entire lifecycle,
from designing, developing,
and distribution.
We give you analytics
insights to help
you optimize your
app and your business
and expand into new markets with
Google's technology assistance.
And without further
ado, we're going
to hear the first of our
deep dives in this area.
I'd like to welcome Ellie
Powers to the stage,
to talk about building your
app for success on Google Play.